[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu einer Spezialausgabe von finde
nach acht fünf Köpfe 5 Meinungen seit
neun Tagen wie die Putins furchtbarer
Krieg die Kämpfe bei dem Ukraine
ukrainische
atomkraftwerksjahr hätten nach Ansicht
der USA leicht zu einem Desaster füllen
können die New Yorker Metropolitan Opera
und andere Opernhäuser legen die
Zusammenarbeit mit Opernstar der
Sopranistin die trepko auf Eis und die
G7 Staaten kündigen weitere noch
strengere Sanktionen an was passiert
wenn Putin verliert und was wenn er
siegt wie weit will Putin noch gehen und
kommt jetzt der dritte Weltkrieg auf uns
zu darüber möchte ich heute Abend in
meinen Gästen debattieren mit
bildchefredakteur und tv-chef Klaus
Strunz mit dem früheren Generalsekretär
der CDU und bundestagsabgeord ziemiak
der uns aus seinem Wahlkreis
zugeschaltet ist mit dem
stellvertretenden Chefredakteur und
führte nach acht Host paronsheimer der
uns wie jeden Abend aus Kiew
zugeschaltet ist Paul ist einer der
wenigen Journalisten die überhaupt noch
vor Ort sind weil seine Informationen so
wertvoll macht L und liest der
Militärexperte Gustav gresse der
kürzlich sagte für Putin soll Russland
ein Imperium sein nun lassen Sie uns
direkt starten mit paronsheimer Paul die
Frage ist natürlich alle bewegt wie ist
der 9 Kriegstag was hast du heute erlebt
ja das Geräusch was mittlerweile auch
viele viertel nach acht Zuschauer kennen
nämlich die Sirene die es heute sehr
sehr häufig wieder losgegangen zuletzt
ungefähr vor zehn Minuten und wir haben
hier in der Nähe des Zentrums ebenfalls
mehrere Explosionen gehört jetzt muss
man abwarten aber um ein Gefühl zu
vermitteln kann ich sagen jeder in Kiew
fragt sich an so einem Vorabend bevor
man schlafen geht wird es heute Nacht
die gefährlichste Nacht wird es heute
den großen Angriff geben und allein das
ist ein wahnsinniger Psychoterror der
auf den Menschen lastet die noch hier
sind ich war heute am Bahnhof habe dort
rührende Szenen erlebt Frauen die sich
verabschiedet haben von ihren Männern
die hier bleiben und kämpfen junge
Frauen die ihre Hunde und Haustiere
mitnehmen nur raus in den Westen nach
Lemberg und dann habe ich petroposchenko
getroffen den ehemaligen Präsidenten der
Ukraine nachdem ich gestern den
Präsidenten selenski getroffen habe und
obwohl beide erbitterte Konkurrenten
sind haben sie etwas gemeinsam sie
glauben dass der Westen Putin immer noch
unterschätzt dass der Westen immer noch
nicht verstanden hat wie gefährlich ist
wird wenn Putin in der Ukraine
erfolgreich ist
petruschenko sagt putin ist ein Killer
und Terrorist er fordert die
Flugverbotszone genauso wie selensky und
genauso wie sie Lenski sagt der wenn
Putin hier nicht aufgehalten wird dann
geht er weiter dann kommen die
baltischen Staaten dran oder wie sie
Lenski gestern sagte dann geht der bis
Ost Berlin
die große Angst die viele Menschen hier
in Deutschland haben mich inklusive die
man jeden Tag spürt wo geht er hin wie
weit wird Putin noch gehen und hier
meine Frage an dich mit der Bitte um
Einschätzung was ist denn
wahrscheinlicher wird er nach Georgien
gehen oder doch wenn er dann weitergehen
sollte ein NATO Gebiet angreifen
er ist momentan natürlich viel zu
beschäftigt mit der Ukraine als dass er
einen weiteren Krieg anfangen würde
militärisch läuft es nicht so wie er es
vielleicht gehofft hat aber auch da
gehen die Analysen auseinander manche
sagen vielleicht nutzt er diese Taktik
einfach um diesen ja dieser Angst diese
Psycho Angst auf das Land zu legen und
danach aber wenn die Ukraine so
vernichtet sein sollte wie er sagt
nämlich er sagt die Ukraine existiert
gar nicht sie gehört zu Russland dann
traue ich ihm alles zu natürlich ist ein
NATO Staat und auch die NATO wird sich
jetzt weiter wappnen eine größere Hürde
aber Wladimir Putin und das sagen alle
Beobachter ist nicht mehr
zurechnungsfähig und das macht ihn so
gefährlich
die Gefahr besteht ja wie Sie Paul
beschreibt ganz real und die Psychologie
die dahinter steckt ist ja das
eigentlich beglemente also wenn ich
alles richtig sehe ist im Moment eine
Situation angerichtet dass Wladimir
Putin machen kann was er will wenn er
Deutschland bombardieren will
bombardiert der Deutschland dann können
wir schauen wie wir uns da verteidigen
und was unsere Antwort ist wenn er in
anderen Ländern einmarschieren will die
er sich noch einverleiben will in seine
Großmacht Fantasien dann tut er das
diesen Proof of Concept diese
Bestätigung dass der Westen dann erstmal
diskutiert und natürlich in der
ständigen Sorge die Reaktion des Westens
löst dann den Dritten Weltkrieg oder
zumindest eine große Eskalation aus das
genau das das Szenario ist der schmerzt
einem ja schon wenn man es ausspricht
weil man irgendwie so machtlos wirkt
gegen jemand der sich nimmt was er will
und der ist hinterlegt mit der Drohung
wenn ihr das nicht zulasst richtig noch
viel schlimmeres an das ist die große
der große Sachverhalt mit dem es sich
jetzt auseinanderzusetzen und es ist
nicht trivial und ich glaube auch dass
alle Führer des Westens sozusagen
Gänsehaut haben wenn Sie darüber
nachdenken weil Putin ja auch geschafft
hat dass quasi die Eskalation dem Westen
zukommt also die Situation ist
psychologischer jetzt so angerichtet
dass wenn der Westen reagiert gibt es
eben die Eskalation ich will aber ein
kleines hoffnungsklammerchen dahinter
machen oder auch nicht denn Wladimir
Putin zieht er jetzt auch dass seine
Armee vielleicht nicht ganz so stark ist
wie er selber und auch der Westen
gedacht hat dass er Soldaten hat die
ihre Panzer im Stich lassen und zurück
nach Russland laufen dass er im Schlamm
stecken bleibt dass er viel stärker ist
als die Ukraine das hat er auch gelernt
aber das ermöglicherweise nicht stark
genug ist die Auseinandersetzung die
militärische Auseinandersetzung mit dem
westlichen Bündnis aufzunehmen das kommt
ihm auch in den Sinn und jetzt kommt der
entscheidende Punkt es ist bei einem wie
ihm wahrscheinlich sogar egal dass er
begreift dass das eine große Gefahr ist
er provoziert sie zu seinem Vorteil und
im Moment wenn man Fazit zieht liegt er
vorn in der Auseinandersetzung er ist in
der Ukraine er hat den psychologischen
Punkt auf seiner Seite wie eben
beschrieben und der Westen weiß nicht so
recht was er machen soll als in seiner
Agenda voranzuschreiten die aber endlich
ist Herr ziemiak liegt Putin vor erstmal
vielen Dank dass Sie sich die Zeit
nehmen dass sie sich hier zugeschaltet
haben aus ihrem Wahlkreis vielen
herzlichen Dank liegt Putin vorne also
hat Herr Strunz Recht das Putin aktuell
vorne liegt
ja militärisch hat er vieles in der Hand
in der Ukraine weil er über starke
Streitkräfte verfügt aber ich sehe nicht
das Putin vorne liegt denn er hat sich
selbst in eine ziemlich ausweglose
Situation politisch gebracht er hat
Russland international isoliert die
Sanktionen greifen jetzt es gibt
Diskussion ob sie noch härter sein
könnten und müssten ich glaube auch dass
wir darüber sprechen müssen was man noch
mehr tun kann aber diese Sanktion die es
jetzt schon gibt treffen Putin hart und
er muss jetzt überlegen wie kommt er aus
dieser Situation heraus und in einem
Punkt würde ich dann Strunz
widersprechen das ist die Frage wie
reagiert der Westen wie reagiert die EU
und vor allem die NATO wenn er
weitergegeben würde gegenüber einem NATO
Staat da sind die Aussagen glasklar das
auch des nato-generalsekretärs aber auch
aller Regierungen östlich von uns jeder
Quadratzentimeter von NATO Territorium
wird verteidigt und wird einen
sofortigen Rückschlag der gesamten NATO
nach sich ziehen das weiß Putin es ist
für ihn ein gefährliches Spiel deswegen
muss man unterscheiden zwischen der
Situation in der Ukraine und was würde
passieren wenn es zu einem Vorfall käme
auf NATO Gebiet aber der Punkt ist ja
eher entscheidet das das muss ja jeden
der gewohnt ist Entscheidungen zu
treffen und erzähl mir das kennen sie ja
aus aus ihrer Teddy und auch das ist
doch das was ein so ohnmächtig
erscheinen lässt er bestimmt die Agenda
er tut etwas und wir reagieren
vielleicht angemessen vielleicht nicht
angemessen aber wie reagieren aber er
hat sozusagen die Hand am Abzug und das
ist das was den Menschen glaube ich
Angst macht weil es sich bei ihm ja
offenbar um jemanden handelt der zum
allerschlimmsten imstande ist
er ist aber das ist eine typische
Situation er ist nämlich der Aggressor
er ist Täter er ist nicht Opfer und es
ist sind auch nicht zwei Parteien wissen
Sie wenn es einen Konflikt gebe wo beide
Seiten wo man diskutieren könnte wie
löst man ihn auch weil beide berechtigte
Anliegen haben das ist hier nicht der
Fall deswegen ist diese Situation so wie
sie sie beschreiben aber das ist typisch
für einen Überfall für einen
Angriffskrieg dass der Angreifer die
Karten in der Hand Halt und es ist etwas
angetreten und damit hat eingetreten
damit hat Putin irgendetwas getan was
ihn zu dieser Isolation jetzt bringt
womit wir aber auch nicht gerechnet
haben ist dieser Überfall auf die
gesamte Ukraine ich will aber dazu
einsteigen wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
haben damit nicht gerechnet wir haben in
Deutschland vielleicht nicht damit
gerechnet aber wenn ich mit Kolleginnen
und Kollegen östlich von und spreche
dann sagen die mir es ist genau das
passiert was wir euch immer
gesagt haben und ihr habt es runter
gespielt ihr habt Business gemacht ihr
habt gesagt wenn die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen stehen dann kann
das nicht passieren und jetzt sind wir
in der Realität angekommen so sagen es
viele Leute in Warschau und den anderen
Hauptstädten
wie er sie damit also ihre Partei hat ja
die Regierung gestellt in den letzten
Jahren das nehmen Sie dann so lässig zur
Kenntnis und sagen ja die haben recht da
haben wir haben jetzt unsere Fehler
aufgedeckt oder wie gehen Sie damit um
das sehr frontale Kritik an der Politik
ihrer Kanzlerin ihre Regierung ihrer
Verteidigungsminister ihrer ich will
jetzt nicht sagen ihn an ihnen selbst
aber
das beschreiben sie jetzt irgendwie so
als sei es und historisches Faktum aber
sie sind ja voll mit drin
also ich persönlich habe die Sachen auch
wenn nicht so wie das gesagt wurde in er
im Baltikum und auch in Polen und den
anderen Staaten so hart habe ich es
nicht gesehen aber natürlich ja klar ist
das Kritik an uns natürlich ist es
Kritik an uns allen die dass wir
beispielsweise nicht unsere
Verpflichtung in der NATO nachgekommen
sind das war fahrlässig aber ich will an
dieser Stelle mal sagen
derjenige der das verhindert hat als
Finanzminister ist heute Bundeskanzler
gut dass er die Kehrtwende gemacht hat
aber wenn sie jetzt fragen wer hat das
verhindert es war nicht die Union es
waren die Sozialdemokraten die jetzt die
Kehrtwende zu Recht einläuten wir haben
es im Wahlprogramm gefordert schauen
sich mal die Aussagen von Saskia esken
an in der sie ja klipp und klar gesagt
hat die Erklärung von Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer mehr für Verteidigung
auszugeben das sei schockierend und das
würde es mit der SPD nicht geben
Herr ziemiak wir hatten gestern hier in
der rundethese die CDU hat ein
putinproblem und ich würde deswegen auch
direkt mal zu paaronsheimer nach Kiew
weiterleiten ist das so wie Herr ziemiak
das hier erklärt Paul dass es nur die
SPD ist also wenn eine Partei ein Putin
Probleme hat dann ist die SPD mit
denjenigen die in Aufsichtsräten und
Vorständen russischer Staatskonzerne
sitzen die das Geld dafür zur Verfügung
stehen die CDU hatte diese Position aber
ich räume es noch mal ein jetzt müssen
wir die Dinge mal trennen die Gefahr
eines Krieges eines Angriffskrieges
eines Überfalls durch Russland haben
viele auch ich so in dieser Form nicht
kommen sehen
Paul wir geben zu dir du hast gerade
schon was sagen wollen das habe ich zu
spät gehört ja was was mir sozusagen aus
der ukrainischen Perspektive immer mehr
auffällt in den letzten Tagen ist dass
ich das Gefühl habe dass sowohl
Beobachter als auch Experten die Ukraine
eigentlich aufgegeben haben wissen Sie
gerade hinter mir hat es wieder geknallt
die Explosion vor 15 Minuten sie reden
und wir reden eigentlich schon darüber
haha kann das irgendwie mit uns sind wir
damit drinnen dritter Weltkrieg ja
versteht man ja jeder Deutsche macht
sich darüber Sorgen und natürlich ist
das die Haustür das wichtigste was vor
der Haustür passiert aber momentan ist
es doch so dass wir die Ukraine immer
noch völlig im Stich lassen wir haben
hier zwar ein bisschen Waffen her
geliefert aber die meisten Waffen waren
Schrott oder sind zu spät gekommen oder
sind nicht genug das heißt sollten wir
uns nicht
ernsthaft mal Gedanken darüber machen ob
da momentan wirklich schnell genug alles
gemacht wird zum einen um Waffen zu
liefern so viele wir haben so viele wir
haben um diese schreckensraketen
abzuschießen die Putin jeden Moment wo
ich gerade sitze hier auf diesen Ort
schießen kann tun wir das das ist das
erste und das zweite ist tun der ganz
kurz erzähl mir es war nicht an sie
gerichtet das mir geht's eher um die
allgemeine Debatte die wir auch hier in
insgesamt in Deutschland und in Europa
führen und das zweite ist ich glaube wir
haben bei den Sanktionen noch längst
nicht alles gemacht mir fehlt da vor
allem die persönliche Komponente was ist
denn eigentlich mit Putins geheimen
Töchtern was ist denn mit Putins
Immobilien was ist denn mit den
Angehörigen auf Schulen Universitäten
überall da habe ich noch nicht genügend
gehört darüber dass künftig alles was
westlich ist für Leute den Kreml direkt
unterstützen nicht mehr zugänglich sein
muss wir brauchen noch viel härtere
Sanktionen
wollen sie noch was entgegnen sonst
würde ich jetzt zu Herrn Strunz
weitergeben
niemand hat weil ich kann das für die
Union sagen die Ukraine aufgegeben ganz
im Gegenteil ich saß im Januar noch in
einer zdf-talkshow mit einem Politiker
der FDP da wurde das Argument
vorgetragen naja wir sollten gar keine
Waffen liefern weil es sei ja gar nicht
möglich überhaupt die Ukraine zu
verteidigen die habe ich wie im Moment
widersprochen und genau das gefordert
was sie gerade gesagt haben jetzt muss
man zwei Dinge unterscheiden
hochkomplexe Waffensysteme jetzt in die
Ukraine zu liefern macht wenig Sinn wenn
man daran lange Menschen ausbilden muss
aber die alle Waffen die jetzt sofort
eingesetzt werden können die Sinn machen
ich bin dafür dass wir diese liefern
herzlichen Dank noch für die Antwort und
dann kommen wir damit weiter zu der
These von Klaus Strunz heute abend gutes
schätzt der die Diskussion nahtlos fort
ich glaube jeder ob am Stammtisch oder
in
politischen Kreisen ob in der Familie
mit den Kindern oder
im unter Freunden diskutiert glaube ich
jeder jetzt wo führt das hin also wie
geht das aus wo führt das hin und gibt
es eigentlich noch ein plausiblen Ausweg
aus der
dauerhaften Krisen um nicht zu sagen
Kriegssituation und wenn man es dreht
und wendet glaube ich dass ein Punkt
sein kann der bisher
ab und zu mal genannt wird ich glaube
nur die
Neutralität der Ukraine liefert
überhaupt noch eine Möglichkeit für
Frieden und es ist eine ziemlich brutale
Sache weil die Ukraine natürlich zu
Recht sagt wir wollen im westliche
Bündnis wir wollen in die NATO Schulen
in die EU das alles von all diesen
Wünschen und Forderungen und
Vorstellungen müsste die Ukraine
zurücktreten warum weil dann auf der
anderen Seite Wladimir Putin der als
einen seiner Kriegsgründe die
Neutralität der Ukraine und die
Demilitarisierung Entmilitarisierung der
Ukraine genannt hat sozusagen zustimmen
kann und schon wenn man das sagt tut es
einem weh müssen wir jetzt Dinge in
Betracht ziehen denen Wladimir Putin der
Kriegstreiber der tyrannte des Boot der
Kriegsverbrecher zustimmen kann ich
fürchte am Ende ist dass die Bedingung
um in eine friedliche Zukunft gehen zu
können das Modell dafür ist das Modell
österreich hat 1955 sich zu einer
Neutralität bekannt also wäre es nicht
ein Weg in die Zukunft die Ukraine mit
dem Modell Österreich und der
Neutralität in Kontakt zu bringen ein
Weg in die Zukunft der uns allen die
Möglichkeit gebe das als ich sage jetzt
bewusst nicht Kriegsziel sondern als
einigungsziel anzustreben
ja also es Österreicher sieht es mir da
alle Bauchkrämpfe zusammen wenn ich das
hört dass die Ukraine nach
österreichischen Vorbild überleben soll
weil das Problem ist das wird sie nicht
dazu muss man auch sagen das Modell
Neutralität lag schon am Tisch also wir
haben ja als der militäraufmarsch zu
diesem Krieg stattfand mehrere Monate
gehabt wo verschiedene
kanzlerpräsidenten versucht haben zu
vermitteln versucht haben zu verhandeln
wo selenski selber auch viele Punkte auf
den Tisch gebracht hat die Putin von
einem Krieg hätte abbringen können hätte
er den Krieg nicht gewollt und nur
diesen Krieg gewollt um die Ukraine zu
unterwerfen einer davon war die Frage ob
man auf den eu-nator Beitritt verzichten
würde das Problem ist Russland gibt sich
zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt mit so einer
Neutralität nicht zufrieden es will eine
entwaffnete Neutralität eben eine
österreichische weil Österreich
militärisch während des ganzen Kalten
Krieges schwach war es will sogar über
die österreichische Neut geht
hinausgehen wenn Österreich vor allen
Dingen ist eine Anfangszeit
amerikanische militärunterstützung hatte
werden sehr viel military eight wir
hatten unsere ganzen Offiziere der
ersten Generation in den USA ausgebildet
und wir hatten sehr intensive Kontakte
vor allen Dingen mit der NATO in Italien
also Österreich hätte zum
Kriegsschauplatz Süd gehört im Falle
eines eines totalen Krieges zwischen der
Nato und dem warschaupackt und wir
hatten sehr starke Verbindungen mit
unseren italienischen Kollegen weil wir
sozusagen dann im Kriegsfall denen
unterstanden wären das auch das lehnt
Putin ab er will eine verteidigungslose
Ukraine eine wo er diesen Krieg zu jeder
Sekunde und für jedes Interesse das sind
gerade durch den Kopf geht sofort unter
besseren Bedingungen wieder fortsetzen
kann als er ihn jetzt führt und das ist
das Problem oder das ist der Grund warum
die Ukraine das zu Recht ablehnt wenn
die Ukraine aus diesem Krieg hervorgeht
und wie Sie aus diesem Ukraine aus
diesem Krieg hervorgeht es gibt zwei
Bedingungen
sie ist souverän die Regierung der
Präsident wird vom ukrainischen Volk
bestimmt und von niemand Andern und das
zweite sie ist wehrhaft in welcher Form
auch immer aber das wäre ja das werden
ja zwei Bedingungen die mit auf den
Tisch müssen wir jetzt zeigen sie
zurecht putin wird sich damit nicht
zufrieden geben mit dem Argument
allerdings kann man praktisch gar nichts
anbieten mit dem Argument bleibt er die
Situation der Ukraine ich formuliere sie
jetzt mal aus der Position des Freundes
der Ukraine
bleibt sie auch eine Art Drohung an den
Westen nämlich entweder ihr seid schuld
daran dass wir untergehen oder wir
ziehen euch in eine nicht mehr
kalkulierbare Eskalation das ist ja im
Grunde das ist ja die Ansage von
silensky mehr oder weniger auf Deutsch
übersetzt und ich finde dass dieser Weg
wehrhaft und selbstbestimmt also
selbstbewusst zwischen den Blöcken das
finde ich ein Modell dass ich noch nicht
aufgeben würde vielleicht denkt Wladimir
Putin im Angesicht der Kriegshandlungen
auch noch mal neu auf was anderes kann
man ja gar nicht setzen weil sonst kann
man sich ihm gleich ergeben hätt ziemiak
ist es ein Modell was man denken könnte
was Klaus Strunz hier kriege skizziert
nein die Zeit ist vorbei und dieses
diese Idee von Klaus Strunz hat einen
Fehler sie unterstellt es gibt zwei
aggressive Teile zwei Parteien die sich
gegenüberstehen beide aggressiv sind und
beide sich überfallen wollen das ist
nicht richtig es gibt ein aggressiven
Staat unter der Führung von Putin nicht
das russische Volk aber die russische
Regierung die ihren Einfluss durch
Expansion durch Aggression geltend
machen will und es gibt ein
Selbstverteidigungs zu Bündnis das heißt
NATO er hat es ist doch absurd herrscht
uns dass die NATO oder die EU das
Staaten aus diesem Verbund Russland
angreifen wollen das Lettland Estland
das Baltikum Polen Russland überfallen
oder die Ukraine nach Moskau marschiert
das ist absurd er hat auch keine Angst
vor einer militärischen Bedrohung
sondern er hat Angst vorm Verlust seiner
Wirkungsmacht in dieser Region dass er
eben nicht militärischer
an einem anderen also ihnen allen an
einem anderen Beispiel sagen wir glauben
daran dass Staaten selbstbestimmt sind
das Regierungen frei gewählt werden
müssen und wenn ein Staat sich
entscheidet sich diesem oder jenem
Bündnis anzuschließen dann haben das die
anderen Staaten zu respektieren und das
Polen beispielsweise in Selbstbestimmung
sich der EU der NATO anschließt ist das
gute Recht des polnischen Volkes
übrigens wäre es auch das gute Recht
wieder aus EU und NATO auszutreten in
diesem Falle würde ja wenn man Putins
Argumentation folgt hätte die NATO hätte
die Bundesrepublik eine recht in Polen
einzustreiten weil man sagen würde Polen
gehört nicht mehr zum Bündnis hat gute
Beziehung zu Russland wir fühlen uns
bedroht das geht nicht was gerade
passiert ist die Neutralität eines
Staates die immer Angst gehabt haben von
Russland überfallen zu werden von Moskau
beeinflusst zu werden und das will Putin
nicht deswegen ist er reingegangen und
das kann die Wertegemeinschaft der wir
angehören nicht akzeptieren okay ich
kann Ihre Argumentation folgen ich finde
sie in weiten Teilen überzeugend aber es
folgt aus ihr außer die totale
Unterwerfung unter Putin wir reden nur
über die Ukraine wir reden nicht über
ihr betreten nato-gebiet dann haben wir
ja klare Verhältnisse wir reden über die
Zukunft der Ukraine der Menschen dort
die jetzt millionenfach aus dem Land
fliehen müssen was ist unser Angebot was
ist unser jetzt sage ich es doch was ist
unser Kriegsziel einigungsziel als
Westen als Deutschland was legen wir auf
dem Tisch ich sage die Neutralität wäre
ein erstrebenswertes Ziel die Hürden
sind mir klar sie sagen die Zeit ist
darüber weggegangen aber welche Zeit ist
dann jetzt angebrochen geben wir die
frage doch mal zu Paul in Kiew Paul du
hast doch bestimmt Lust zu antworten
ja Klaus wirft da tatsächlich die größte
Frage und das größte Problem auf ich
will vielleicht mal aus ukrainischer
Perspektive sagen warum ist so schwierig
ist für die Ukraine überhaupt in
irgendeine Verhandlung zu gehen oder
irgendetwas zu unterschreiben wenn das
denn aus Putin sich möglich wäre 1994
wurde der Ukraine eine
Sicherheitsgarantie gegeben und zwar von
Russland und dem Westen im Gegenzug hat
die Ukraine die Atomwaffen abgegeben das
Vergessen immer viele ursprünglich war
die Ukraine genauso wie Russland eine
Atommacht die wurden 1994 abgegeben weil
man gesagt hat wir werden euch niemals
angreifen wir sehen diese Garantie hat
zu nichts geführt das heißt all das was
jetzt kommt wenn man sagen würde okay es
ist eine dermaßen eine militärische
Übermacht auf russischer Seite wir sind
bereit hier Neutralität zu geben wobei
das innenpolitisch ein riesiges Problem
wäre weil viele viele Menschen das nicht
wollen aber nehmen wir an man würde das
machen wie kann man denn Putin vertrauen
dass er sagt okay ich gehe da nicht rein
ich mache das nicht wer wer soll ihm
denn Vertrauen dass er in einem halben
Jahr das nicht tut oder im nächsten Jahr
das das ist das große Problem und das
große Dilemma aber ich gebe Klaus recht
was ist dann die Lösung ich muss sagen
ich habe keine Antwort darauf auf diese
Frage und ich finde und zwar deshalb
auch weil Vladimir ganz kurz ein letzter
Satz weil Wladimir Putin ja sagt die
Ukraine gibt es gar nicht das ist alles
Russland
also ja das ist das Dilemma gar keine
Frage aber ich frage mich auch wenn die
Menschen in der Ukraine sagen wir wollen
diese Neutralität nicht sondern wir
wollen dass der Westen uns hilft laden
Sie auch eine große moralische
Verantwortung auf ihre Schultern denn
das bedeutet wenn wir sterben sollen
sollt ihr im Westen auch sterben denn
ihr sollt dann in diese kriegerische
Handlung eintreten diese Forderung liegt
ja auf dem Tisch lasst uns nicht allein
ihr müsst uns helfen ihr müsst Luft
den Luftraum sperren das bedeutet ein
Eingriff der nach internationalen
Gesetzmäßigkeiten gedeutet werden kann
als sozusagen die nächste
Eskalationsstufe und auf die wartet
Wladimir Putin nur also glaube ich dass
man dem Gedanken der Neutralität so
schmerzhaft er sein mag und die kinke
ist natürlich kann man einem Mann
vertrauen der ein gerade überfallen hat
der gerade die Brüder die Schwestern die
Kinder die Eltern
töten lässt kann mit dem Vertrauen die
Antwort liegt auf der Hand nein aber was
bleibt sonst und das hat mich zu dem
Gedanken gebracht von allen Optionen
Dritter weltkriegt durch
Eskalation Ukraine geht unter unter
russischer Herrschaft irgendwelche neuen
Grenzen werden gemacht und Putin hat
gewonnen gefällt mir irgendwie die Idee
wenn man das so sagen darf der sich die
neutralitäten noch mal einen Weg bahnt
der Gedanke der Neutralität noch am
aller allerbesten aus unserer Sicht
wenn du aber da möchte ich einer hier
Gegenfrage aufstellen sorry ja aber
nicht nur die Ukraine ich würde
bezweifeln ich würde bezweifeln dass
selbst Wladimir Putin das akzeptieren
würde wie soll er denn sagen in er hat
in seinem reden in seiner letzten
Ansprache ganz klar gesagt die Ukraine
gehört zu Russland das bedeutet ja er
will sie sich einverleiben und sie soll
in dem Sinne keinen Staat bleiben dann
würde ja Wladimir Putin auch die
Neutralität nicht reichen Klaus
also wenn man nicht dann letzter Gedanke
wenn man nicht daran glaubt dass man
Wladimir Putin etwas hinlegen kann was
ihn vielleicht interessieren könnte
diplomatisch als politischen Erfolg ich
komme ja immer von diesem furchtbaren
Gedanken dass er sein Gesicht wahren
können muss nach der Auseinandersetzung
Sie interessiert mich eigentlich gar
nicht ob ein Mörder und Kriegsverbrecher
sein Gesicht waren kann aber es scheint
mir der einzige Ausweg zu sein dann
müssen alle die sagen Neutralität ist
keine Option doch was anderes auftischen
und sagen dann lass es uns so versuchen
und das habe ich noch nicht erkannt ich
würde mich auch ich sag's jetzt flapsig
Schock für lieben in ein anderes Modell
das mir so plausibel erschiene wie die
Neutralität die schwierig genug ist
in den Krieg erst einmal verlieren oder
zumindest so großen Schaden nehmen dass
er sich mit dem überhaupt mit der
Realität überhaupt abfindet dass er
einen Ausweg braucht denn zurzeit geht
er nur auf die Maximalforderungen auf
eine totale Entwaffnung der Ukraine und
das kann kann ich das Ziel sein und dann
ist es auch so hey die Ukraine braucht
die Ukraine kann nicht auf Treu und
Glauben spielen die Ukraine braucht eine
wehrhafte Situation in der sie sich
verteidigen kann ob sie sich durch
Allianz mit anderen verteidigen kann
oder ob sie genauso wie das im Fall
Jugoslawiens nach 1948 war wie das im
Fall Österreich nach 1955 war wobei
österreich hat zu einem guten Teil
versemmelt und das später nochmal teuer
gekommen aber seine andere Geschichte
die nur Österreich interessiert oder ob
das etwas Schweden war in kalten Krieg
oder die Schweiz aus einer
Selbstverteidigungsfähigkeit und bei bei
vielen neutralen Staaten die
vorangesprochen habe eine unterstützte
Selbstverteidigungsfähigkeit die USA
haben 1956 als die russischen Panzer
durch Budapest rollten sofort eine
Garantie ausgesprochen dass jede
Verletzung Österreichs unmittelbare
militärische Konsequenzen durch die USA
hervorrufen sie haben nuklear bewaffnete
Flugzeuge nach Mitteleuropa verschickt
die Service haben das sofort verstanden
das hat niemand für die Ukraine gemacht
und wenn man wenn sich der Westen dann
auch nicht bewusst ist was es bedeutet
einem bündnisfreien hoch verwundbaren
Staat hier zu haben dann können wir alle
Papierformen der Neutralität über den
Buckel schmeißen weil Putin das Papier
nicht interessiert den interessiert
knacken meine Panzer das oder nicht wir
bleiben beim Thema Putin und kommen noch
zu einem Thema was mir heute Abend sehr
wichtig ist und zwar das Putin nicht
Russland ist die Wut über Putins
Angriffskrieg ist groß in Deutschland
man merkt auch hier in der Runde doch
sie verwandelt sich fälschlicherweise
auch in Zorn auf Unbeteiligte nach
Mitstudenten und russische Restaurants
als sei jeder mit russischem Hintergrund
Putin Fan das darf nicht sein was mich
besonders schockiert eine Mail über die
zuerst die Zeit berichtete die
Direktorin der Universitätsklinik
München schrieb Zitat aufgrund der
schweren völkerrechtsverletzung durch
den offenbar geistig gestörten Putin bis
hier in Stimmung noch zu jetzt nicht
mehr leben wir ab sofort grundsätzlich
die Behandlung russischer Patienten ab
ukrainische Patienten natürlich herzlich
willkommen sie hatte diese Mail an eine
Beraterin verschickt über Umwege landete
diese dann auf Facebook auf Anfrage von
ZEIT ONLINE teilt das Krankenhaus dann
mit dass sie sich keineswegs mein
offizielles Statement der Klinik handle
die Absenderin hat in einer sehr
emotionalen Situation ihre persönliche
Meinung mitgeteilt die es aber
inzwischen bereits bedauert ich sage es
nicht gerne und ich sage es nicht oft
aber es sind schon Menschen für weniger
zurückgetreten als für sowas und es ist
nur ein Symbol für das was in
Deutschland los ist auch wenn die
viertel nach acht Redaktion haben sich
in den letzten Tagen Russen gewandt in
Deutschland leben und gebeten dass
Passieren der Runde für sie einsetzen
das möchte ich hiermit gerne tun putin
ist nicht Russland Hass auf alles was
russisch ist darf nicht die Antwort aufs
Putins Krieg sein ich bin nicht die
Einzige ist heute anspricht hätte
ziemiak sie haben heute auch in der
Union Mario Czaja der amtierende
Generalsekretär dazu heute auch ein
Statement abgegeben deswegen würde ich
direkt zu ihnen übergeben mit der These
ja ich teile das auch ganz ausdrücklich
Mario Chaya hat das gemacht heute in dem
Statement wie ich fand richtig und und
klar und deutlich Friedrich März hat
einen offenen Brief geschrieben auch an
die Russlanddeutschen das ist ja wir
dürfen diesen politischen Konflikt
diesen Krieg von Putin nicht zu einem
Teil unserer Gesellschaft werden lassen
wo Menschen ausgegrenzt werden weil sie
eine Herkunft haben wie zum Beispiel die
russische und ehrlicherweise können wir
darauf stolz sein was wir in Deutschland
haben wissen Sie in dem Hochhaus in dem
ich groß geworden bin da gab es im
Prinzip drei Gruppen das waren Russen
und Ukraina und Polen in im Laufe der
Jahre wir haben zusammen als Kinder
gespielt später als wir etwas älter
waren haben wir zusammen auch was
gegessen und
ich musste einmal kurz überlegen aber
mit dem Essen das hätten sie mir nicht
abgekauft und so haben wir immer denn
wir sind in eine Grundschule gegangen
wir kennen uns bis und deswegen sage ich
ich teile das ganz ausdrücklich dass es
putinskrieg und das die Russlanddeutsche
Ukraine die von dort gekommen sind das
sind deutsche Staatsangehörige häufig
und insofern sage ich wir sind eine
Gesellschaft und deswegen keine
Diskriminierung
Paul wie ist die Lage in Kiew wenn du
dort mit den Menschen sprichst natürlich
auch über Russland ist es dort auch dass
man auch feststellt was in der Situation
ehrlich gesagt auch anders als in
Deutschland ein Stück weit
verständlicher ist dass der Hass auf
alles russische groß ist oder es anders
als hier in Deutschland
nein es ist natürlich sehr viel
intensiver als in Deutschland aber man
muss sich das auch mal vorstellen ich
meine es ist ja nicht so dass nur
Wladimir Putin hier in einem Panzer
steht und die Ukraine angreift sondern
eben hunderttausende russische Soldaten
ähm ich stimme all dem zu was ihr gesagt
habt natürlich gerade
darf es nicht zu diesen Vorfällen kommen
ist für mich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
dass das nicht passieren darf und
dagegen müssen wir uns alle Wehren und
dennoch muss ich sagen es ist eben nicht
nur putinskrieg denn es gibt sehr viele
Menschen die dafür gesorgt haben dass
Vladimir Putin Präsident wurde er war ja
auch mal ein anderer Präsident das
stimmt zwar er war beliebt und ist
beliebt es gibt viele Menschen Peter
Tide macht das immer wieder sehr
eindrucksvoll unser Reporter in Russland
wenn er dort mit den Menschen spricht
die kaufen in das alles ab dann kann man
sagen okay die sind jetzt vielleicht
alle gebrandwurst durch diese
Massenpropaganda die es dort wir haben
gerade gehört dass Facebook jetzt auch
offiziell blockiert ist also Russland
entwickelt sich momentan Richtung
Nordkorea aber dennoch hat natürlich die
russische Gesellschaft eine
Verantwortung dafür wer Präsident
geworden ist und die russische
Gesellschaft hat genauso eine
Verantwortung dafür dass sie in diesem
Moment als dieser Krieg ausgebrochen ist
mit einer viel größeren Anzahl von
Menschen hätte demonstrieren müssen ich
weiß das ist alles leicht gesagt auch
aus der Ukraine leicht gesagt als
Reporter leicht gesagt der sich nicht
hier gegen die Polizei stellen muss aber
ich würde mir wünschen und ich hätte
auch erwartet dass die Zahl der
Demonstranten gegen Putin wesentlich
höher ist und wenn es einer sagen kann
Paul bis es du der sich ja jeden Tag mit
Mut in der Ukraine in Kiew auffällt also
ich finde wenn es einer sagen darf dann
dude du darfst es verlangen meinen Augen
Klaus wie siehst du die Situation
von Paul fast ein bisschen zag
ausgesprochenen Gedanken noch verstärken
wollen jeder der Putin gewählt hat hat
Anteil an diesem Krieg es Mitschuld an
diesem Krieg den Putin hat sich ja quasi
nicht irgendwie besonders verwandelt
also er hat sein Äußeres ziemlich
verändert wenn man das so sagen darf
ob freiwillig oder aus Krankheitsgründen
wird der heftig diskutiert aber er es
war ja völlig klar dass es sich nicht um
ein lupenreinen Demokraten handelt den
man da wählt also in Deutschland jedem
klar du solltest klar sein
einer der unterirdischsten Sätze der
wahrscheinlich der jemals gesagt wurde
er Gerhard Schröder über Wladimir Putin
und da ist es ja auch immer schon so
eingeordnet worden und deswegen kann man
jetzt nicht per Blanco scheinen die
gesamte russische Bevölkerung und
Wählerschaft freisprechen ist es nur
dieser eine verrückte Mann und seine
seine
Olli geichen klicke und ein paar
generale sondern das ist schon
der führt da schon aus was viele Russen
für richtig halten das muss man sich
schon klar machen aber jetzt umgekehrt
darf daraus auch nicht der Schluss
gezogen werden alle Russen wollen die
wollen Kiew platt machen im Gegenteil da
da da tickt in mir auch sowas was für
mich das ganze noch unvorstellbarer
macht also gibt dir ganz viele
persönliche Beziehungen in russischen
Familien zu ukrainischen Familien und
wahrscheinlich würde man bei den 150.000
Soldaten ganz viele kennen die wenn sie
auf Kief Schießen auf ihre Cousine
schießen oder auf entfernteren
Verwandten oder Narren Verwandten also
das ist ja das ist ja quasi aus
deutscher Sicht fast nur zu begreifen
wenn man sich vorstellt dass ich in der
Bundeswehr ausgebildet worden bin um auf
die NVA zu schießen ja also deutsche
Schießen auf deutsche das ist dann noch
die verrücktere Steigerung von allem
hier allerdings um die Freiheit zu
verteidigen
und und nicht sie abzuschaffen so und
das finde ich ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Punkt bei der beurteilt der
Russen die gibt es halt nicht jetzt muss
quasi einen Satz noch dazu sagen auch
nicht alle Ukrainer sind lupenreine
Demokraten ja also auch da gilt es
natürlich zu unterscheiden nicht aber in
dieser Stunde denn in dieser Stunde
kämpfen die einen für die Freiheit und
die anderen gegen die Freiheit und dann
hat man sich als freiheitsliebender
Mensch nicht mehr groß fein zu
zisilieren sondern dann steht man auf
der einen Seite und gegen die andere
Seite ich will noch
eine Gaga eine ziemiak Stellen ich
brauche nur eine ganz kurze Antwort aber
leider müssen wir dann kurz unterbrechen
jetzt sie merkt fanden sie heute die
Sanktion gegen die Opernsängerin eine
trepko richtig von den Opernhäusern
weltweit
das ist also in einer kurzen Antwort
schwierig zu sagen ich finde das sind
diejenigen also ich würde mir mehr
Sanktionen wünschen übrigens gegen
diejenigen die das Geld hier auch in
Europa haben diejenigen die den
westlichen Luxus den Lebensstil gerne
pflegen in Demokratien sie sicher fühlen
aber Krieg mit ihrem Geld finanzieren
auf diese Antwort weil man nämlich an
der Antwort gesehen hat so kurz und
einfach ist es gar nicht bei jeder
Persönlichkeit zu erklären ob sie jetzt
russisches oder nicht wir sind nach
einer ganz kurzen Unterbrechung wieder
zurück
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und wir wollen direkt zu
dem Thema beziehungsweise eigentlich der
Sache kommen warum ich heute unbedingt
hellcymiak in dieser Sendung haben
wollte und ich bin so froh dass er sich
dazu auch heute dann kurzfristig halt
auch überzeugen lassen nicht von mir
sondern vor Paul sei mal aus aber was
ich dazu nämlich sagen will sie haben
gestern waren sie an der
polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze und haben
Flüchtlinge besucht und ihn auch
geholfen und wir würden uns sehr freuen
wenn Sie uns die Eindrücke schildern die
sie dort gestern erlebt haben Herr
ziemiak
ja ich war im Grenzübergang
medica wo viele eben einer der großen
coinsübergangspunkt Profile Ankommen im
Auto wartet man bis zu 72 Stunden zu Fuß
geht es schneller aber trotzdem viele
Frauen dort die 24 Stunden gewartet
haben kann man diesen
grenzübergangspunkt hp-organisation vor
Ort besucht hat mir die Infrastruktur
angeschaut und habe mir eben auch von
der polnischen Grenzpolizei alles zeigen
lassen von diesem Übergangspunkt kam
dann plötzlich eine Familie und zwar
eine Mutter mit drei Kindern die nach
Hamburg wusste wo sie Angehörige hatte
und wusste nicht wie sie dorthin kommen
soll die grenzpolizistin fragte mich ob
ich helfen könnte ich habe dann gesagt
dann nehme ich sie mit oder wir nehmen
sie mit ich war mit einem Freund
zusammen da und dann kam noch eine
andere Familie
ein ein Rentnerpaar mit Enkelin und dann
haben wir die gleich mit eingepackt und
sind mit unserem Bulli dann von dieser
ukrainischen Grenze bis nach Hamburg
gefahren
und sie sind ja auch in einem
durchgefahren wie ich im Instagram Post
gelesen habe was haben die Menschen ihn
denn vor Ort gesagt was bedeutet jetzt
wirklich am meisten benötigt was sie
auch ganz ganz viele Bürger in
Deutschland fragen wie kann man helfen
ich würde sagen die Hilfsbereitschaft
war selten so groß wie gerade in diesem
Land ja absolut Dienstbereitschaft ist
gigantisch nicht nur bei uns in
Deutschland ich habe das auch in Polen
so in der Form auch noch nie erlebt man
sieht in Warschau keine kein Bus keine
U-Bahn die der nicht eine ukrainische
Flagge hat auf den Straßenschildern auf
den digitalen Anzeigen in Warschau auch
auf den polnischen Autobahnen wechseln
die Verkehrshinweise dann mit help
European citizens auf Englisch mit einer
Helpline die dann eingeblendet wird also
eine unglaubliche Solidarität überall
ukrainische Flaggen und auch egal ob
Regierung oder Opposition ich meine das
hat Putin geschafft in Polen Regierung
und Opposition bei einer wichtigen
politischen Frage zusammenzuführen und
vielleicht ist er sogar derjenige der
ganz wichtig mal dass ukrainische Volk
noch einmal zusammengebracht hat aber zu
der Hilfe bitte das würde ich sagen
keine keine Kleidung schicken an die
polnische Grenze dort kommt sehr sehr
viel an aus Polen auch aus Deutschland
manchmal hat man den Eindruck da will
man was gutes tun und wirft Sachen weg
die sowieso man gar nicht mehr
gebrauchen kann das kommt dort an das
ist nicht das was man braucht auch bitte
keine Konserven in Deutschland kaufen
und die dann mit einem Lkw nach Polen
bringen weil man kann in Polen sogar
selbst im Supermarkt Dinge einkaufen
also man kann einfach Geld spenden das
hilft am ehesten wenn man helfen will
ich empfehle dazu entweder ganz konkret
Initiativen vor Ort auf der polnischen
Seite Initiativen in der Ukraine oder
eben die anerkannten Hilfsorganisation
und zwar von der Aktion Deutschland
Hilft jeder der dort registriertes
mitmacht der ist zertifiziert und da
lohnt sich eine Spende
Klaus wir helfen ja auch bei Bild mit
ein Herz für Kinder
hat auf eine große angelegte Aktion
gestartet kann man in all unseren Medien
sehen
das finde ich ganz ganz fantastisch ich
würde es ein bisschen an einer Stelle
vielleicht anschärfen wollen das was
Paul ziemiak über die
Altkleidersammlungen in
Anführungszeichen sagt bewegt mich auch
also ich glaube dass die Bilder über die
vielen Menschen in Not viele Menschen in
Deutschland extrem berühren und
gleichzeitig so eine Art schlechtes
Gewissen auslösen dass man nicht genau
weiß wie man helfen soll oder dass man
wüsste wie man helfen soll aber es ist
so unbequem also hilft man lieber nicht
und dann schaut man mal im Keller ob man
noch ein paar alte Kleider hat die man
dann dahin schickt ich drücke es einmal
ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige der
bitte so sagt und da glaube ich müssen
wir noch zu uns finden also wenn eine
Million Menschen auf der Flucht sind
oder vielleicht wie ich jetzt von der
UNO gehört habe womöglich 10 Millionen
und wir so nah dran sind dann ist es
natürlich mit einem alten Winterpulli
nicht getan sondern dann ist die Frage
haben wir Gästezimmer haben wir sutere
Wohnungen haben wir in Villen Platz für
Menschen und ich finde das ist da
es gibt Null Zusammenhang und trotzdem
fühle ich den man kann schon sagen ein
russischer Oligarch dem soll man sein
ganzes Vermögen wegnehmen aber dann muss
man auch sagen wer jetzt hier in
Deutschland ein großes Vermögen hat den
Immobilien der soll sie auch öffnen für
Menschen in Not und ich habe ganz am
Anfang schon mal gesagt dass ich Angst
habe vor den
laberbataillonen die dann beginnen
rumzulaufen die immer alles wissen wie
es gehen muss die immer alles
prophezeien und predigen dann muss man
auch selber Dinge tun und es fällt
unheimlich schwer ich habe diese
Diskussion mit mir selber und meiner
Familie auch gestern begonnen was was
tun wir denn und dann kommen da auch so
Argumente naja aber dann wie ist es denn
dann sitzen alle beim Frühstück zusammen
mit den fremden Leuten und so also ja
das muss man ja einmal auch annoncieren
weil wir könnten natürlich noch viel
mehr tun anders gesagt wenn wir uns
schon so schwer tun Waffen zu schicken
dann sollten wir uns wenigstens um die
Menschen kümmern die darunter leiden was
die Waffen der anderen innen antun und
das bewegt mich sehr und ich habe bin
weit davon entfernt zu sagen ihr müsst
ihr müsst ihr müsst ich sage nur lasst
es auf euch wirken wenn ihr Menschen
seid dann fällt euch sicher irgendwas
gutes ein was die Abgabe des
Winterpullis und der durchgelatschten
Schule übersteigt
darf ich darf ich vielleicht noch einen
Punkt hinzufügen mir geht mir ist ein
Punkt noch wichtig wir erleben jetzt
eine unglaublich große Welle an
Hilfsbereitschaft aber ich habe heute
zum Beispiel eine eine ein vereinbesuch
bürgerheft Bürgern bei mir in Iserlohn
die das übrigens nicht nur jetzt tun
sondern die ganze Zeit also über Jahre
hinweg Menschen helfen die auf der
Flucht sind und die Not sind und meine
bitte ist an diejenigen die heute helfen
wollen aber noch nicht wissen wie macht
euch einen Zettel legt in den Kalender
für in einem Monat oder in zwei Monaten
drei Monaten wenn vielleicht man gar
nicht mehr so genau hinschaut wo es
vielleicht auch zu lassen wird weil es
wird auch mit Herausforderungen versehen
sein wenn so viele Menschen nach Polen
kommen nach Deutschland kommen um dann
auch zu sagen jetzt sind wir dabei wenn
keine Kamera mehr hinschaut ja vielen
herzlichen Dank jetzt sie merkt für
diesen Aufruf der sehr wichtig und ja
auch ehrlich gesagt im Sinne von dieser
Talkshow für nach acht deswegen noch mal
vielen Dank und sie bleiben uns jetzt
hier in der Runde erhalten wenn es jetzt
auch zur these geht die muss ja auch
eine mitgebracht und sagen nämlich was
die Ukraine jetzt braucht eigentlich ja
die Ukraine braucht es in erster Linie
Waffen werden wir von Spenden reden ich
habe es jetzt natürlich nicht da aber
ich kann auch das Spendenkonto der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte aus dem Hut
zaubern bzw aus dem Handy und sie
brauchen natürlich mehr als die Spenden
von mir denn die Ukraine steht mit dem
Rücken zur Wand das erklärte Kriegsziel
Russland ist es die Ukraine auszulöschen
ist unabhängiger Staat als
eigenständiger Nation was Putin so
euphemistisch als endnazifizierung
beschreibt ist nichts anderes ist ein
ausradieren der politischen kulturellen
der journalistischen Eliten der
intellektuell
der Westen hat allen Grund aus sogar aus
einfach aus blanken eigenen Interesse
die Ukraine hier mil selbst unterstützen
denn wenn die Ukraine fällt wenn dort
wie in der DNR und lnr ein
Besatzungsregime das sich dann mit
nordkoreaderaumpolt den letzten Platz in
der Freedom House Ranking zu erfüllen
werden sich das die Ukraine nicht
gefallen lassen sie werden Widerstand
leisten es wird im Partisanen Krieg
geben was bedeutet das wiederum Russland
wird zehntausende Truppen der innen
sicher der Nationalgarde FSB entsenden
um diesen Aufstand niederzuschlagen
diese Leute kommen vor rot nach Russland
zurück behandeln die eigene Opposition
wie sie es in der Ukraine gelernt haben
und Ukraine versteift und Russland
versteinigt sich drauf wie das Putin
gestern schon angeklungen hat dass der
Westen an allem schuld ist dass im
Grunde das nur ein Produkt der CIA ist
und dass man das altbewährte Mittel
militärische Kraft und militärische
Einschüchterung dazu gebrauchen wird um
uns abzuschrecken und ich sage das unter
Anführungszeichen sich in die und ich
wieder Anführungszeichen inneren
Angelegenheiten Russlands einzumischen
das wird der Putin sprech sein wir
werden keinen ruhigen den Krieg haben
wir werden einen heißen Kalten Krieg
haben einen der äußerst instabil ist und
in einem in der die Eskalation im Grunde
jeden Tag an der Wand geschrieben ist in
dem Sinn ist es unser ganz ureigenstes
Interesse jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass die
Ukraine in diesem Krieg zumindest
militärisch Unentschieden aussteigt und
ihn auf jeden Fall überlebt als Ukraine
als souveräne Ukraine
Paul du hast es hoffentlich gehört ja
was gibt es darauf zu antworten wie
viele Waffen braucht die Ukraine
wie viele ist schwer zu sagen aber
definitiv kann ich sagen vor der Sendung
mit Vitali Klitschko gesprochen der
heute an verschiedenen Stellungen
unterwegs war auch hier in Kiew muss ich
das ja so vorstellen um hier herum wird
längst sehr heftig gekämpft insbesondere
den Außenbezirken da sieht es so ein
bisschen aus wie in Teilen Syriens
bereits so sehr schießt Russland dort
mit
Raketensystem rein Öl es geht vor allem
darum dass man diese Raketen abwehren
kann das ist kompliziert zumindest
teilweise und dennoch gibt es dafür
Möglichkeiten und da sagt die Ukraine
brauchen wir dringend viel viel mehr
woran ist der Ukraine nicht mangelt und
das hat Putin überrascht ist die Moral
der Truppen die man dort auch treffen
kann die wirklich überall unterwegs sind
versuchen hier auch hier wo ich bin
diese Stadt in irgendeiner Form sicher
zu halten das ist trotzdem wahnsinnig
geisterstimmung dort in den Straßen das
fährt eigentlich niemand mehr es läuft
auch niemand mehr so wirklich über die
Straße aber was die Waffen angeht sagt
man das geht zu langsam die Europäer
brauchen zu lange
man orientiert sich momentan eigentlich
vor allem Richtung USA und das ist finde
ich ein wenig traurig dass wir Europäer
da im Vergleich zu den USA wieder
bürokratischer langsamer und nicht hands
on sind ich glaube wir müssten alles
alles tun um wirklich hier europäisch zu
liefern denn ich erinnere mich wie 2014
dort von vielen EU-Politikern
europäische Flaggen verteilt wurden am
Maidan ich sage das jetzt mal symbolisch
sie standen zumindest mit dabei und die
Ukraine die jetzt die europäische die
damals die europäische Flagge gehisst
haben gewählt haben auf dem madan die
stehen jetzt auf dem Schlachtfeld und
drohen von Putin getötet zu werden Herr
Ziem Zaudern die Deutschen wirklich so
viel mehr als die Amerikaner vor allem
mit Blick auf die Sanktionen muss ich
sagen also Amerika zaudert gerade ja
auch ein bisschen mit Blick auf den
Energiepreis auf jeden Fall wird es dort
auch debattiert wie man das mit den
Bürgern schafft sind wir gerade so viel
schlechter im Handeln als Amerika
haben auch mit einigen Sachen länger
gebraucht zum Beispiel auch mit der
Flugverbotszone aber es war richtig es
ist richtig was sie sagen wir haben
gezaudert wir haben gezögert und als
schon alle anderen gesagt haben wir
brauchen die Aussetzung von SWIFT was
Deutschland die am Ende noch die
einzigen waren vorher noch mit Viktor
Orban die einzigen die dagegen waren
selbst zypern hat schneller entschieden
als wir und insofern ja wir haben nicht
schnell gehandelt bis letzte Woche
Sonntag als Bundeskanzler Scholz seiner
Regierungserklärung abgegeben hat waren
wir diejenigen die gebremst haben und
die nicht geholfen haben dann gab es die
Wände und die war richtig und das hat
Scholz das will ich auch als Opposition
sagen das was ihr angekündigt hat war
richtig ich habe als der Vertreter der
Neutralität noch eine Frage wenn man dem
Gedanken näher tritt also
Waffen Waffen Waffen das ist ja ein
einfacher Gedanke insofern leicht
verständlich was wäre dann ihr Szenario
wie das weitergeht glauben dass man in
der jetzigen Situation die ja schon weit
fortgeschritten ist
der Armee Putins noch wirklich
Widerstand leisten kann so dass das
passiert Achtung meine These ist immer
noch im Raum das Putin so viel Schaden
nimmt und so viel Gegendruck spürt dass
man überhaupt am Verhandlungstisch mit
was eigenem ankommen kann ja also ich
würde hier die Parallelen zu 1939
Finnland ziehen stalin war ja auch jetzt
nicht zimperlich und war jetzt auch
nicht der beste Menschenfreund und hat
sich auch nicht um die Menschenrechte
geschert aber irgendwann war es einfach
für die Sowjetunion damals zu schwierig
oder zu zu problematisch dass man hier
in Finnland vorgeführt wird Finnland
stand natürlich auch vor der totalen
Erschöpfung Finnland hat aber auch
zumindest von Schweden zum Teil auch von
Frankreich und Großbritannien Waffen
bekommen um um sich zu verteidigen und
es hat dann nach 40 Tagen wir sind jetzt
am Tag noch in der Kriege Finnland hat
nach 40 Tagen einen natürlich
schlechten aber einen souveränen Frieden
und einem bewaffneten Frieden erreicht
und wir sind zurzeit wenn man sich die
letzten Verhandlungsrunden zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland anschaut leider
noch weiter von entfernt das Putin einem
souveränen und einem bewaffneten einen
wehrhaften Frieden für die Ukraine
zustimmt wie immer der dann ausschaut
Ukraine die Ukraine hat ein sehr
lebhaftes Parlament das müsste allen
zustimmen was selenski aushandelt das
Vergessen ja bei uns auch die Leute der
ist nicht Putin der ist ein Wort ist
nicht Allmacht aber wenn er einen
Kompromiss aushandelt dem dem die Rader
zustimmt dann dann gilt der und was dann
genau drin ist dem möchte ich nicht
vorgreifen denn bis es dahin kommt ist
noch viel militärischer Widerstand zu
leisten und wir haben natürlich die
logistischen Probleme der russischen
Armee die Konvois die die Kolonnen das
ging bei uns alles durch die durch die
Medien aber das gilt ja für die
ukrainische Seite genauso die russischen
Panzer die hier alle abgeschossen sind
die haben sich nicht in selbst in
Flammen aufgelöst die wurden
abgeschossen und da wurde Munition
Verbrauch und der Munitionsverbrauch war
enorm auch zur Raketenabwehr die Ukraine
hat es geschafft sogar russische
ballistische Raketen abzuschießen mit
alten sowjetischen Flugabwehrraketen
aber auch die wären knapp
und desto länger sie das kann desto
länger sie eine Luftwaffe noch betreiben
kann desto länger sie den Luftraum
zumindest temporärfreiheiten kann
solange sie noch Drohnen operieren kann
die gegen diese konvoice gehen die auch
Artillerien der Tiefe angreifen solange
sie noch eine funktionierende Panzer
Abwehr hat die die verhindert dass die
Stadtzentrum wirklich eingenommen wird
solange hat die Ukraine eine Chance
einen Frieden auszuhandeln der kein
friedhofsfrieden ist und der nicht auf
potenziell passiert
kein friedhofsfrieden wir haben gestern
mit einer kleinen Tradition begonnen die
heutzutradition mit Paul kannst du noch
mal in 40 Sekunden die letzten 40
Sekunden der Sendung ich glaube sogar 45
noch einmal deinen Kriegstag heute noch
einmal schildern für die die später
zugeschaut haben
noch einmal zu schildern ist schwierig
weiß ich jede Minute hier was neues
ergeben gerade eben hinter uns hat man
Schüsse gehört im Stadtzentrum das nicht
das erste Mal aber immer wieder ganz
kurz davor immer wieder Explosion sie
reden also und das Gefühl in dieser
Stadt und das ist das was die Leute
fertig macht was für ein Terror sorgt
immer das Gefühl zu haben du gehst jetzt
ins Bett aber du warst Morgen auf und
der große Putin Angriff hat begonnen und
die großen Raketensysteme werden
eingesetzt und du schaust wehrlos zu wie
deine Stadt zerbombt wird wie einst
Aleppo in Syrien
lassen wir es so enden mit deinen Worten
Paul vielen herzlichen Dank an meine
Gäste und wir sehen uns Montag abend
wieder um 20 Uhr tschüss
[Musik]